In the very first immunology
video, where we talked about
nonspecific defense mechanisms,
we said if we had
some type of a pathogen-- let's
say it's a bacteria--
that our phagocytes can
recognize either proteins on
the bacteria or maybe it was
some other type of pathogen--
some other marker
on the pathogen.
It doesn't know what type of
pathogen it is, but that's
enough for the phagocyte.
It'll engulf the pathogen.
So let's say this is
the phagocyte.
Somehow one of their receptors
touches one of the proteins
that's on the surface of this
bacteria in this case and
says, gee, that's not a good
thing to have around and so
it'll engulf it.
So the membrane is just going to
surround the pathogen-- and
this part is going to go in.
It's going to kind of pinch in
and the pathogen is going to
get surrounded and
get engulfed--
phagocytozed by the phagocyte.
So the end product-- we saw this
on the first video where
I talked about phagocytes-- is
we're going to end up-- so
then the membrane's going
to be completely around.
This is going to pinch in and
bubble around this thing and
so we're going to have
the pathogen sitting
inside of the phagocyte.
It's going to be surrounded
by a membrane.
That membrane's called
a phagosome.
And we learned there's
different types of
phagocytes-- could be a
macrophage, could be a
neutrophil, could be a dendritic
cell-- and we have
it like this and then we also
saw in that video, it's not
just done-- the macrophage
doesn't
just digest this thing.
That by itself is very useful.
It got this bacteria
out of the way.
If this was a virus, it got
that virus out of the way.
But it does even
more than that.
It takes that and then it lyses
it-- or it breaks it up.
It doesn't have to actually
use-- well, it breaks it up.
There's several ways it can do
it, but the bottom line is, it
processes it.
It'll break up the pathogen--
and we saw that first video on
phagocytes that we'll actually
have a lysosome bond to it and
dump all sorts of particles that
are going to break up and
cut up this bacteria,
in this case, into
its constituent molecules.
And then some subset of the
leftovers, particular chains
of the peptides-- and remember,
proteins are long
chains of amino acids.
Polypeptides are short chains.
So you take short chains of
those and they're going to
bond to special proteins.
And this is essentially the
topic of this video.
So let's say they bond to that
special protein, bond to that
special protein.
And then those proteins get
transported or get to the
membrane or the outer surface
of the cell and they present
themselves along with the
piece of the pathogen.
So the end product after
phagocytozed this pathogen is
that the phagocyte will look
something like this and it
will have these antigen
presenting proteins, I guess
we can call them, that had
bound to parts of that
original pathogen.
Let me do it right here.
So it has a little bit of the
original pathogen on it that I
drew in green right here.
And these proteins right here,
these are called-- it's a
fancy word and I talked about
it in the previous video--
these are called major
histocompatibility complexes,
or MHC for short.
And when we're talking about
phagocytes or macrophages or
dendritic cells that are
particular cases of
phagocytes, the major
histocompatibility complexes
that they present after
they've digested this
molecule-- this is
an MHC class II.
Let me write this down.
This is an MHC class
II protein.
It might seem like I'm really
going into the minutiae of
what these proteins are, but
we're going to see this is key
for activating other parts of
the immune system, especially
the cell mediated parts
of the immune system.
So this was the case with a
macrophage or a dendrite.
They engulf something, they chew
it all up, and then parts
of the chewed up thing that they
ate, they attach to these
MHC II proteins and these
MHC proteins go to the
surface of the cell.
The same thing-- or actually not
the quite the same thing--
a very similar thing happens
with B cells.
So if we have a B cell--
that's a good color.
B for blue.
We know B stands for bursa, but
it could stand for bone
marrow just as well.
Let's say we have a B cell and
it's got its membrane bound
antibody on it.
Remember, it's very specific
to that B cells.
So all of the membrane bound
antibodies, all 10,000 or so
of them on this B cell, they
all expressed the same
variable part.
So this is a particular
B cell.
So remember, this
was nonspecific.
When we talked about
phagocytosis, these guys just
say, you're a bacteria.
You're a virus.
I don't know what
kind you are.
I'm just going to eat you up.
You look shady.
I'm going to eat you up.
I don't know what type
you are or whether
I've seen you before.
When we're talking about B
cells, we're talking about the
adaptive or the specific
immune system.
And so these-- the variable ends
of these membrane bound
antibodies are specific to
certain parts of certain
pathogens, to certain
epitopes.
Remember, epitopes were the
parts of certain pathogens
that these specific chains can
recognize and bond to.
So let's say that we're
dealing with a
virus in this situation.
And let's say the virus
just happens to
bond to this B cell.
Remember, there might be
other-- in fact, there
definitely are tons of other
B cells around, but their
variable portions are
all different.
And that's what I always find
amazing about B cells is that
they come from the same genetic
line, their genes have
been shuffled around in their
development so that they can
produce billions of combinations
of these
proteins, or the variable ends
of their antibodies.
So let's say we have
some virus.
Let me say it's a bacteria.
When I did the other B cell
example, I said we're dealing
with viruses.
But let's say some new bacteria
and just some part of
its surface just happens to
bind to only this B cell--
because this B cell has just
the right combination.
So some part of his surface
binds just to that B cell
right there.
That part of the surface that
binds, remember, that was
called the epitope.
That's that part of the pathogen
that binds to our
variable sequencer.
It won't bind to this B cell
or this B cell because they
have different sequences here,
but it binds to this B cell
and then that starts the
activation process.
We'll go into-- sometimes this
by itself can get the B cell
activated, but you normally
need help from helper T
cells-- and we'll talk
more about that.
And we said, once this
happens, once you get
activated or the activation
process starts, this guy
actually gets engulfed-- and I
didn't talk about that in the
last video just because I didn't
want to go into too
much detail.
So this whole thing gets
engulfed by the B cell.
And then when it gets activated,
it proliferates
itself and you normally need
the T cells there and some
part of them become plasma B
cells, some part of them
become memory B cells.
Remember, the plasma B cells
say, gee, I've been activated.
I'm just going to produce a
ton of these antibodies.
So the plasma B cell will just
produce tons of these
antibodies and start spitting
them out so that they can
attach to more and more of that
pathogen and just mess
them up in different ways,
either tag them so that other
macrophages or phagocytes eat
them up-- or tag two of them
so you bundle them up so that
they can't operate properly.
Whatever.
I'm not going to go into
detail on that.
That's when it gets activated.
But the interesting thing is
that the B cell will also do
what the phagocytes do.
The B cell will also take
this guy into the cell.
Maybe he's initially attached
to the antibody-- and break
him up, take pieces of this
pathogen and attach it to MHC
II proteins and then present
them on the surface.
So a B cell will also
present the antigen.
So this is also an MHC
II complex-- a major
histocompatibility complex--
and just so you know, histo
means tissue.
So this is related to whether
something is compatible with
the tissue in your body and
we'll talk more about that and
how it relates to transplants
and all of that.
So this is also an
MHC class II.
In both cases, whether we're
talking about B cells that
recognize a very specific
pathogen-- and it could be a
specific virus, a specific
protein, a specific bacteria,
or in the cases of phagocytes,
they'll just say,
oh, you look shady.
Let me take you in.
I don't know what type of
bacteria or virus or protein
you are, but in either case,
they both engulf them, take
pieces of them, cut them up,
and present them on their
surface in a complex
with the major
histocompatibility complexes.
So cells that do this are called
professional antigen
presenting cells.
This is what they do for a
living, although they do other
things, as we've seen.
The phagocytes eat things.
The B cells generate antibodies
or memories so that
they can later be activated to
generate antibodies, but these
are called professional antigen
presenting cell.
And the antigen in question is
this little piece of the
actual thing that you're trying
to track, that little
piece-- the actual part of the
pathogen, that's what the
antigen-- so it's presenting
the antigen.
It's professional because it
takes pathogens from in the
fluid of our system and then
engulfs them, breaks them up,
and then presents them.
Now there are also
nonprofessional antigen
presenting cells.
And in fact, most
cells are this.
In fact, even these guys.
Actually, I'm going to wait
for the next video.
I realize all of my videos
are getting long.
So you're probably thinking,
these guys in either case
engulf them, cut them
up, present them,
what is it good for?
You'll see these MHC II, these
are what are recognized by
helper T cells.
It'll all form part of the
puzzle of how our immune
system works.
So in the next video, I'll talk
about MHC I presenting
cells, which is pretty
much all body cells.